ne sait plus ne sait pas ne sait pas
quand et comment sortir de l'union
décision je dirais géostratégique
funeste prise par un peuple aujourd'hui
désorienté que l'on a year tromper suite
un référendum décidé par l'ancien
premier ministre david cameron qui n'a
rien trouvé de mieux que de prendre
l'europe toute entière en otage pour
régler tout simplement un problème
intérieur monsieur le ministre
bruxelles a pris hier la décision de
prolonger une nouvelle fois la date de
sortie de la grande-bretagne de l'union
ma question est simple pourquoi une
telle décision
et surtout comment contrôler la
sincérité et l'attitude des 73
parlementaires britanniques à nouveau
présent demain au parlement européen à
une période particulièrement critique où
il faudra voter le nouveau cadre
financier pluriannuel et surtout la
nouvelle composition de la commission et
son président je remercie pour vous
répondre
la parole est aux listes de l'europe est
les affaires étrangères monsieur le
drian
oui monsieur le président bizen je
partage évidemment vos interrogations
j'ai dit tout à l'heure en répondant à
une autre question que le bric site ne
pouvait être une attitude permanente et
qu'on ne pouvait pas vivre dans nil dans
le pack site permanent dit dans le pré
qui cite éternelle et la décision qui a
été prise cette nuit permet de respecter
quatre principes fondamentaux pour nous
tous d'abord les intérêts de l'union
européenne ensuite le vote démocratique
britannique
ensuite la nécessité d'un processus sans
ambiguïté en particulier sur la
renégociation
je lui ai expliqué tout à l'heure et
enfin l'unité des 27
ces quatre principes ont pu faire
l'objet d'un accord général c'est une
bonne chose
le souci principal c'est que le bon
fonctionnement l'union européenne soit
préservée et à cet égard des garanties
ont été apportées par la grande bretagne
dont il faudra s'assurer de la bonne
mise en oeuvre d'abord
le fait que pendant cette période la
grande-bretagne s'engage au devoir de
coopération loyale
c'est la moindre des choses deuxièmement
que les vingt-sept puisse pendant cette
période se réunir à 27 pour préparer des
dossiers qui viendront après la sortie
de l'union de nuit européenne de la
grande bretagne
troisièmement que l'échéance de cette
nouvelle prorogation a été fixé avant
l'entrée en fonction de la nouvelle
commission
si bien qu'une des questions que vous
vous posez finalement est réglé par
cette observation et enfin quatrièmement
il ya un engagement britannique a
organisé des élections européennes s'il
est encore membre
et s'il n'a pas alors ratifier l'accord
de retrait avant l'échéance électorale
sans quoi le retrait interviendrait le
1er juin date à laquelle il y aura à
nouveau conseil européen de vérification
des engagements pris par la grande
bretagne dans l'accord de cette nuit
désormais je pense qu'il ya un chemin
finale et nous souhaitons que la grande
bretagne soit sur ce chemin aussi
limpide que les vingt-sept l'ont été
cette nuit
merci monsieur le président visé merci
monsieur le ministre pour cette réponse
je vous l'avais je vous la vrai qu'il me
rassure guère vous rassure-t-elle vous
même je n'en suis pas si sûr
aogo vue si celui d'hier du du parlement
de westminster et de la présentation par
nos amis parlementaires britanniques
depuis quelques mois je crains qu'il ne
reproduisent à bruxelles
je dirais la même séquence c'est à dire
'faites d'inconséquence et
d'incohérences et désormais je crains qu
en europe
l'immobilisme avance et rien ne pourra
l'arrêter vous remercie merci